hi
uh
it doesn't matter how uh
long a person does ikea in in my opinion
we get asked questions
from unlike hidoka
many of the questions are the same you
know year in year out
because new people come in and they want
to know
the same questions as
those before them but occasionally
we will get one that uh surprises us you
know i haven't been asked that before or
a great question
and in some conversations and some of my
zoom conversations i have with
one-to-one aikidokas or
several groups
i suddenly realized that i'm talking
from
many years of experience
and
when i first started aikido
we had that you know life was different
it wasn't
the speed it's going now we didn't have
mobile phones
we didn't have internet
you know and
almost sounds prehistoric talking about
it now
but we didn't have this media facebook
twitter
tick tock you know so it goes on
but what we do have
then and now
is
the worry in our minds the daily
stresses and strains of family work
just life in general
and
i was trying to think back that when
bringing up a young family and running a
business i still had all the stresses
and strains
and these
i don't know about other continents but
the western world
in democracies we tend to think and ask
questions a lot
then we start asking questions of
ourself in our own head
one question i was asked was about the
defeat positions in
aikido
and i was explaining that in taijitsu
the stance is
open with the back foot wider than when
doing the weapons
in 1983 cytosenses sent a student a
swiss a student who was uchideshi at the
time
he said before going back to switzerland
on your way home calling to tony
and
you know
help him with his aikido
that was a great honor for me and uh
for scentsy to
think of me
in that way
boosted me from then and for many years
on
anyhow
i trained
every single day doing something can joe
on my own
walking in the mornings with my dogs
and what i
realize now is the things that i'm
talking about and teach
i didn't have to really learn
because
a lot of them were inbuilt
so when the student was asking about the
feed
i realized watching
other students
how light their
footsteps were when moving across the
tatami or on hard floors
and of course you can't be inside
somebody's head
but
i suddenly realized that
most of them are using arms to swing the
ken or joe and the strength in the upper
body
where if you train every day
and and training then let's say three
four times a week physically on the mat
we never used to talk in those days on
the mat where now
chatter seems to be
90 of the training time
i'm sure in japan they still have strict
rules where you just train
but i know this more and more than my
seminars
and i've got fed up with saying it now
you know no talking please just
concentrate
but it wasn't part talking just was not
part of our
training same as we didn't have mobile
phones in the background going off
when we were training
to remind us of the world that we live
in
so
once we put our gear on and stepped onto
the mat
we were coming from a
perhaps a stressful life
even not as stressful as today's
living
but it was stressful to us
we hadn't speeded up to the
21st century quite so fast then
so we would arrive at the dojo put on a
key
and the moment you step on the map it
was like stepping into another world
you didn't need to talk because the
techniques were done quite fast
we used to do four of each
two on one side two on the other then
our partner would do it
and at the pace it was done
you only had time to breathe because it
was more cardiovascular than technical
we thought we were doing the techniques
correctly of course but um
looking back on it now
it was more like fighting with each
other
calling it aikido
so i'm explaining this to try to get to
the point of how do i teach you
what you
can't do or don't do
now in your training
but you need it to be a good martial
artist you need grounding
in the orient they talk about the
the center of the body the horror
and how you put everything lower than
your also your belly button
um this is your central point and just
below the navel
about five centimeters below your navel
is where
you're supposed to think of your
central point
where your mass
goes downwards not
upwards the western mind thinks
and
it's a little bit like yeast
rising in bread
so when i see people walking
um
in daily life
and you can check this out for yourself
this is what the whole purpose of this
film is about
training daily those who've been through
or those who've trained in a dojo on a
regular basis
will understand what i'm talking about
you become very exhausted the body
becomes very tired
but the enthusiasm to want to do the art
more and more
um grows
but as the body gets very tired
we start to relax more the body gets
without us knowing it the harwa does
naturally
take place
and if you train with someone who trains
daily
um
or go to one or a place that's intense
you will find them much more solid much
more difficult to move
they haven't changed their weight
perhaps they weigh the same as you if
you stood on the weighing scale
but their mass
hasn't gone
downwards
not upwards
and it's done this naturally
so those very very few of you that might
be listening to me
who do that training
you don't have to do anything just keep
training daily
and
working
your body hard
and you won't need to learn this
for the my majority though
i'm going to add this small piece in
if you can talk less on the mat
you've got more of a chance of lowering
your mass
because going inward and concentrating
on what you're doing
but don't go inward
too far
and forget that you've got a partner or
partners
they are the most important thing in
training aikido
don't just work with them but
think that it's you that's perfecting
the technique without them you'll never
perfect the technique
that can perhaps be for another film
okay so what i'd like you to do is you
can do in daily life whenever you get a
moment to think perhaps a spare moment
or walk into the shops or walk into the
canteen
walking around your house your apartment
wherever it may be in the garden in the
park
just start
treading
with your feet
and
pressing them firmly into the ground on
each step
some uh
monks
in their system
each morning
they will
walk
and they will move their feet at such a
slow pace
most of us will not be able to hold our
balance
on the one leg
as we transfer
slowly to the next step
hovering across the ground
at perhaps millimeters distance between
our foot and the ground
the aim is
to
force your body
and your mind to create mass
because without this mass in your lower
half of your body
so when you call forth
to do a technique on someone or to throw
someone
this power
must be called upon instantly
you can't at the time think i must think
down when you're about to throw somebody
upwards
but if this mass
is slowly built
drip by drip by drip
into the feet
and you start to feel the feet as they
press into the ground
the depth of this tread the depth
we can all do it doesn't take a
scientist or magician to
press deeper into your feet
and realize how light
you normally walk in every daily life
you know try
the moment you can either put me on
pause or
if it's
burning in your head to try it
well try it after this film
but walk around and notice how
you go from light
to firmer steps
these firmer steps
you're going to if you're not training
daily you will have to keep applying the
same as any other aikido technique
you must do it regular
until your steps become
[Music]
almost
like elephant steps
placing all that power all that weight
all that mass down into the ground
starting from the feet it should rise up
not starting from the head thinking of
all your worries and your concerns and
even techniques
and trying to push that down
from the head
through the body
it's almost an impossible task because
you know we've got these
big shoulders we've got a torso that's
bulky
it's very difficult to feel any
sensation going through the body
but you can feel it through the feet
and you slowly press into the feet and
as you do that you'll slowly be able to
come up into this shins into the calves
and and like all
human beings we will try to rush the
process
you cannot watch the process
next year will be my 50th year in aikido
and i'm still learning
it's the joy oh sensei said
as long as your aikido is joyful
then you're doing it correctly
but we need challenges of course we need
challenges but make this challenge an
enjoyable one
and each and each time you do it you
will find the mass under your feet
comes quicker
at first you might have to keep pressing
down each one each one
and then perhaps after a few attempts
the first press will be much more
powerful
than a few days or weeks before
and this means that you're training the
body memory
to react to the thought memory
okay
so i hope this helps you
it's a very important part of your
aikido structure
don't worry about oh if i get too heavy
will i be able to move yes you will
it's your mind that's playing tricks
with you and doing uh
but what if
in aikido we've not got room for but
what ifs we've only got room for
training training in the correct way
building a like you know building our
mats
building our zan chin
awareness
and i'll finish off by saying
remember
talking distracts
the inner body the inner mind
be at peace
just train
if you have to talk make it
minimalistic
and
avoid
too much confrontation with your partner
you're there to train it's a short
period on the mat
yes
if you want friendliness make it
afterwards
in the club
in the bar or wherever you wish to meet
but the tatami is
hard training
physical
mental
enjoyable
thank you for listening